pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
planté là les cordes kruger est bien le
bon la loi mais je ne sais pas les
chroniqueurs abandonne chez darty mobile
assez bons retours font du sens à
travailler un peu j'ai travaillé et j'ai
fait travailler manger
il a oublié sa bague
la cas là je pense que je vais dire en
direct
vraiment c'est aussi la tienne et des
bas mais leurs voix et la cg retrouver
jean rémy peut-être la dernière fois
aussi messieurs part peut-être j'ai
complété ma dernière fois tu veux être
acteur et tu fais quoi de jean-michel du
doubs jean michel maire
encore battu de leur donnons mac il est
sûr de rien et défaut la révision est
filmé
et jouera tous ces messieurs vous faire
un petit extrait wishna gueule ces
animaux part de l'agencé aux exigences
et aux premières répétitions avec les
autres attraits rappeur avec 7 de
wingles et d'animaux ou alors va
tranquille effet pas le show mais y'a
pas la musique c'est pour ça qu'on a vu
sur une musique personnelle d'un bon
flop
ouais moi c'est plutôt tata yoyo que le
coach est toujours là
on a des binaires la wish mayotte immo
faut que je possède le texte pour après
bien que ça surprend un peu d'énergie je
vais tout faire pour me faire taire
je les séparent de mai
pêche au thon des balles la regarde
[Musique]
regarde on attend qu'un seul à manger
par l'important c'est parti pour deux
mois le ton monte avec 31 voix japonaise
de thon si tu repousses appel je vous
souhaite aujourd'hui je sais pas j'ai
prix d'europe
[Musique]
gerin vous faire ça mais ça c'est bien
bien à prendre deux fois par ans un
spécialiste du rang sur 30 wiroth des
grog va au café du croisement témoins et
tu fais quoi
[Musique]
un week-end entre move à côté j'ai pris
[Rires]
[Musique]